On the uneven bars.
Chris, this could be the highlight of the compulsory event.
She is one of the technically strongest, best gymnasts that I have ever seen.
Watch this.
Beautiful rhythm, right to a handstand.
Oh, look at that amplitude.
She is really moving well.
Another handstand, look at that!
Right to the handstand.
Gorgeously shaped. Beautiful, and the crowd loves it.
It wasn't just the crowd that loved it.
There it is!
A perfect ten for the first time.
No gymnast in Olympic history had ever received a perfect score.
And to do it with a compulsory routine was phenomenal.
It brought the crowd to its feet and brought Nadia back onstage for a curtain call.